hey guys today is a 2 year anniversary
my channel berry relates the balloons oh
yeah
I don't have a berry oh well that's ok
but yeah today's actually the 2 year
anniversary of this particular channel I
was amazed because people were sending
me emails about it and thank you guys so
much we've come so far in just two years
we're almost at two and a half million
subscribers and making that progress in
such a short amount of time well it
seems short to me but it's two years as
long part of my life but just thank you
guys for supporting me all the way
through this and you know it's not the
official two year anniversary of the
time I've been on YouTube I actually had
a channel before this one that got
closed down because the various reasons
with YouTube and Adsense and all that on
funny entertaining stuff that I don't
like to talk about anymore but still
it's it's a it's a moment to celebrating
just to thank you guys again for all
that you've done for me and I know that
I thank you guys a lot but I just really
enjoy the opportunities that you've
given me and I want you guys to always
know that I'm always grateful so I'm
gonna keep saying it no matter how
annoying it gets to you guys I am super
grateful also I was reminded of my old
channel very recently because I was just
on scare to care which is a show that's
a yearly charity show run by Bernie Shaw
and his brothers and a whole bunch of
other youtubers joined where we raise
money for camp Cassim which is for
children with cancer and it's a very
great charity and I was happy to be a
part of it and thank you guys so much
for the last-minute arrival to that and
you still blew away all expectations
just thank you to everyone who donated
to that cause I was only there for three
and a half hours but we've still raised
fourteen thousand dollars and that's
with me not giving you guys any warning
about it so thank you guys so much but I
mentioned casually on the show that I
had a channel before I have this channel
right here where I played a bunch of
other games and I tried different things
and I didn't know who I was as an
entertainer just yet and before that I
was actually doing a Minecraft series on
what I had markiplier won and markiplier
- so I have this whole set of videos of
this entire playthrough of Minecraft
that I did 50
three episodes ten minutes and longer
some of them are like 20 minutes of just
me totally crapping out on minecraft and
being awful at it and being awful at
commentary and and a lot of people send
me emails about it saying that they
wanted to see it they actually wanted to
see my terrible terrible minecraft
playthrough maybe you guys will find it
entertaining but there was enough people
that wanted it that I actually uploaded
every single video and there is a secret
unlisted playlist that can only be
accessed through the link in the
description below I don't even think I
can annotate an unlisted playlist but it
is down there the link is there and the
only way you can get to all fifty three
episodes of young markiplier fooling
around and not knowing what the hell
he's doing is through that link so if
you really want to see it feel free to
watch it feel free to make fun of how I
was before feel free to go oh you is
just a little baby and he was adorable
and didn't know what he's doing so it's
there for you guys to enjoy please do
it's a blast from the past and I think
it's kind of appropriate being that this
is my two year anniversary of the
channel so just thank you guys so much
for getting me to this point because
I've developed as a person and as an
entertainer since then and it's always
good to look back on certain things and
I'm actually working on a mine
markiplier highlights right now that is
uh almost entirely older videos and it's
crazy to see myself back then in those
days it's just kind of weird to watch
myself back then I'm kind of go like oh
is that funny I don't know if that's
funny but still it's good to be in touch
with who I was because I've always felt
it's important to be grounded especially
after coming this far so just know that
I haven't forgotten the past you know I
just try to be better every day but at
the same time I know that a lot of
people really think that my old stuff
was the best stuff so with this series
and markiplier highlights that are
coming out later this week I really hope
you guys understand that you know I
haven't forgotten about
I haven't forgotten about the time when
we were a smaller channel and just that
closeness of the community and the
community that I really want to build is
so very important to me and I hope it's
important to you guys and the website's
coming I'm working on that right now
should be just two more weeks Siri
they'll be up and ready for you guys to
use forums I'll have a blog there we can
share a bowl bunch of stuff it'll be
ready to go so thanks for that oh and
speaking of minecraft I had some good
news because I recently got together
with wade Bob and zombie mold and a few
of zombie molds admins on the server
that he runs and we are bringing back
drunk minecraft bigger and better than
ever I know that the fan community
around drunk minecraft is massive and
you guys are so dedicated and I'm so
unbelievably appreciative of what you
guys have done to support me in that
show it's one of my oldest running shows
and we are bringing it back bigger and
better than ever while still maintaining
the core aspect of it which is just
three friends [ __ ] around blowing
stuff up but it's gonna be even better
because there's gonna be multiple admins
behind the scenes that are working as we
are recording to mess with us and
basically ruin everything that we try to
do not that we did anything anything any
way that we did anything any way and
hopefully it'll be in every way and
hopefully it'll be an even better
experience so there's gonna be like four
cameras running in the background I'm
gonna spend way more time editing them
they're gonna be just a bigger event and
the fans are going to be involved in
episodes that's right we have actually
recorded done some test recordings where
we actually had fans playing with us and
we want to get you guys involved because
the community has been so awesome we
want this show to be as much yours as as
it is ours so we're gonna have a lot
more information to how you guys can get
involved with the show and it's gonna be
so amazing so thank you guys for your
amazing support amazing can I say
amazing more it's amazing there's one
more thing I wanted to talk about in
something I was supposed to make a video
about about two weeks ago um some of you
may have noticed that my stuff is in the
most recent loot crate yeah oh that's
loot crate my stuff is in the most
recent loot crate and I know what the
hell I'm doing
and I failed to mention it to you guys
and that's where I dropped the ball
because the stuff that's in here is no
longer available in the future ones but
I just wanted to show you guys what was
available so that you could see and
hopefully you guys aren't mad at me too
much I'm sorry so let's get this open
okay so anyway loot crate if you don't
know what it is it's this monthly
subscription service that allows you to
get a box full of probably more than
what it costs worth of stuff and I've
already seen what's in it because I've
seen other people celebrate what's in it
and there's this really cool t-shirt
that is linked and it says a courageous
soul it's got a whole bunch of words I
love these word art things like this
where it's just a character that's built
out of words like someone did this of my
face
and it was oddly weird but that was a
long time ago and I really loved it was
very well done all slogans that I've
said in the past but anyway the
subscription service is like I think
it's 1337 per month base price and each
month you get a box like this and
usually if you buy a t-shirt like this
you may even pay twenty bucks so it
might be worth it already
Oh minecraft hangers hi wake up wake up
I need the back leg rim light on my
beautiful hair so anyway we got
minecraft hangers in area that says each
pack contains one hanger so I don't know
what this is
Oh God it's a duck it's a piggy dummy
hey JEP oh that's adorable creepy
because he's a zombie and Dedan wants to
kill me but horrible anyway moving on
yeah whoa what is this oh it's some
cartoon network thing is this oh it's a
vet it's an adventure time duty daddy
thingy I know exactly who this character
is
his name is Gunter and he's a penguin on
a TV show called The Adventure Time that
a lot of people liked and would be mad
if I didn't know about oh that's not
good sir I have no idea who I know
exactly who this is as well
this guy's potato but he's potato but
the cat and a lot oka no go get why no
potato but is definitely okay and not
broken and I shouldn't be given nice
things because obviously good for
doesn't know what happened to potato but
in there happen everybody nothing sorry
bunny the don't wouldn't anyway so we
also got who is that a bottle opener oh
yeah not many people know but I used to
be a bartender actually probably a lot
of people know because they talk about
all time but I used to be a bartender
how cool is that
there it is you guys press on through
the plastic but I got it out because I
can it's also a button this is lootcrate
adventure a lot of people like buttons
especially conventions they collect them
or something cuz they're usually free
anyway here's the main course of the
attraction CaptainSparklez
so anyway yeah there were markiplier
tattoos in here and I've seen a lot of
pictures of people who had these tattoos
on and I'm gonna actually try to put
these on right now on my face there we
go so I'll be right back
oh I shouldn't have cut the instructions
in 30 seconds yet come out tomorrow
thank your bottom dollar buyers probably
done okay I'm gonna assume it's done so
uh BAM I won't actually know if this is
actually done until way later so I'm
just gonna assume because it's gone
there that it's actually on my face so
alright for that happening now the next
one tomorrow
Oh
[Music]
oh I'm sorry
perfectly the way down I'm Batman I'm
Batman for the worst thing on my
forehead so no one plays ignore me
make sure the dive in damp nobody we
hold on with him how I actually warm up
with the mornings this is a nice hard
dick did it work
okay so I have no idea if it actually
worked so hooray
markiplier tattoos let me see pictures
of you and more inconspicuous locations
than this maybe not
don't do that there's actually a lot of
Polaris channels that are featured in
the loot crate this month and it's
really cool to see because cam sparkles
got stickers as a friend zone
soundtrack and there's a whole bunch of
other symbols tickler here and i'm
actually got another sticker again so
I'm actually really proud because I like
how it's featured two times I guess
Capitals also
talk on that so anyway it's just really
cool to see that all these youtubers are
featured in the crate and if you don't
know what loot crate is I think I
described it enough and with showing us
hopefully you guys will know what it
means
but there's a link in the description
below where you can get a 10% discount
on a new subscription or something like
that
I hope it's still valid because once
again I want to say that I am late to
the party on this one and hopefully you
guys can still take advantage of it if
you have before it already
so obviously the stuff in this crate is
worth more than the price you'd pay so
give it a look let me know what you
think and as always I will say no not
time for that yet I need to look like
less than an idiot alright so thanks
again loot crate for having my stuff in
the box you guys can check the link in
the description as you can see it's
definitely worth more than the price you
pay which is probably 13 bucks
they have discounts for actually signing
up for more months so it's even better
deal if you guys like what you see
obviously link in the description but do
what you want it's your life I can't
make you do anything let me look at me
I'm an idiot so with all that being said
thank you guys again for an amazing two
years I don't know when I'm ever gonna
quit YouTube but I don't have any plans
anytime soon in another two years I
imagine myself sitting in front of a
camera for you guys acting like a [ __ ]
so thanks again everybody so much for
watching I hope to make this the best
year possible I've already got the next
charity livestream planned that's gonna
be an official one that I'm running and
I've got a special new item that is not
shirt that I know you guys are gonna
absolutely love so thank you guys so
much for everything that you've done
this for me I can't wait to see what we
do in the next few years so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
my owner by